now the law of this relation of the two
sides would have to state the kind of
affect and influence exerted on the
individuality by these specific
circumstances but this individuality
consists precisely both in being the
universal and hence directly and
unresisting ly coalescing with the given
universal the customs habits etc and
being conformed to them and in setting
itself in opposition to them and in fact
transforming them and again in behaving
towards them in its individuality with
complete indifference neither letting
them exert an influence on it nor being
active against them therefore what is to
have an influence on the individuality
and what kind of influence it is to have
which really mean the same thing depends
solely on the individuality itself to
say that by such and such an influence
this individuality has become the
specific individuality means nothing
else than that it has been this all
along circumstances situation customs
etc which on the one hand are shown as
already there and on the other hand is
present in this specific individuality
Express only the indeterminate nature of
the individuality which is not the point
under consideration if these
circumstances way of thinking customs in
general the state of the world had not
been then of course the individual would
not have become what he is for all those
elements present in this state of the
world are this universal substance the
fact however that the state of the world
is particularized itself in this
particular individual and it is such an
individual that is to be comprehended
implies that it must also have
particularized itself on its own account
and have operated on an individual in
this specific character which it has
given itself only in this way would it
have made itself into this specific
individual
well that he is if the Constitution
which the external world has
spontaneously given itself is that which
is manifest in the individuality the
latter would be comprehended from the
former we should have a double gallery
of pictures one of which would be the
reflection of the other the one the
gallery of external circumstances which
completely determine and circumscribe
the individual the other the same
gallery translated into the form in
which those circumstances are present in
the conscious individual the former the
spherical surface the latter the center
which represents that surface within it
here in paragraph 306 what we see Hagel
doing is working out further the
implications of the duality that we've
already noticed between the individual
and the world or the universal what it
is that that's forming them what it is
that the laws of psychology are supposed
to be providing some intelligibility to
explaining for us how it is that factors
outside of the control of the individual
things that impinge upon him or her form
and shape the consciousness of that kind
of person so what we're talking about
are things like we put here customs in
Germans hittin habits given height and
what you're used to circumstances the
oom stand up the the things that you
know literally are all around you and
the situation the laga and for each of
these people think that they can come up
with some sort of generalization and
it's not just supposed to be a
generalization it's supposed to be
universal in scope so let's see how this
plays itself out here we begin to see
the the role that freedom is going to
play within the Hegelian system in fact
as sort of a side note anybody who
thinks that Hagel is purely a
determinist in the classic sense where
everything is just part of one big
determinism and nobody has any freedom
isn't reading these passages so this is
a very important part of the text
prefiguring a lot of what other Hague
aliens and other people influenced by
Hagel who are not hey galleons for
instance jean-paul Sartre right and
Being and Nothingness are going to do
with the individual so he says the law
of this relation of the two sides the
world in the individual these two sides
would you have to state the kind of
affect and influence exerted on the
individual by the circumstances by all
of this stuff over here but and here is
where Hagel points out something very
interesting the individual is him or
herself already a universal in a sir
way how so well we're going to see that
the individual we've already seen this
in the previous paragraph engages in a
kind of adaptation or interpretation of
these norms these sociological or
psychological norms that are supposed to
have all of the determinative force on
their side it turns out and again this
prefigures what's art has to say in
being and nothingness and also in
existentialism as a humanism that it's
the individual who gets to decide on
some level what to make of those
supposedly determining forces so he says
this individuality consists precisely
both in being the universal and directly
and unresisting ly coalescing with the
given universal the this is the
universal as provided with us so on the
one hand if the individual allows him or
herself to do this they will in fact be
shaped by these forces for example when
they're inattentive when they think that
their customs or the ways in which
things are done in their country their
family their community is the best way
and they don't question that day they
end up being shaped by it informed by it
on the other hand it's quite possible
for something else to occur as Hagel
says so he says here we go the and and
setting itself in opposition to them
setting itself in opposition to these
norms over here the customs the habits
and in fact transforming them now that's
something really interesting to say it's
not just opposition it's not just saying
no it's not just a refusal there has to
be a process of reinterpretation of
assimilation of sifting of deciding what
one is going to keep and what one is
going to reject a plain flat no means
nothing within the Hegelian system at
this point you could say really
throughout the entire system hail is a
big fan of what it calls determinate
negation which means negating but
in a certain way in a way that has a
positivity to it rather than a mere
blockage a mirror no aamir refusal so he
goes on and he says here we go again in
behaving towards them in its
individuality with complete indifference
neither letting them exert an influence
on it nor being active against them
that's another possibility you can say
oh there's norms in place I'm just not
going to observe them I understand that
they're there but i'm going to make use
of my capacity my freedom my option and
just ignore them so he says therefore
what is to have an influence on the
individuality and what kind of influence
is to have said I've got this here we
think of the world as exerting its
influence but really it's crossed by the
own individual saying well I'm only
going to allow this to affect me and I'm
going to allow things of this sort to
affect me and we might also say we could
add in a couple other qualifiers the why
the when the how all of those sorts of
things it's not totally under a person's
control of course but there is quite a
bit of that involved here much more than
people often give credit to we have
choices about what kind of people we're
going to be shaped by the norms that we
have so we can say well I come from a
family that does XYZ that doesn't
necessarily have to determine a person
because if it did then like mechanisms
we would automatically replicate that
that process or those norms so he goes
out and he says these depends solely on
the individuality itself to say that by
such and such an influence this
individuality has become this specific
individuality means nothing else then
that it has been this all along so
there's something going on here in this
process a you might say hidden exercise
of freedom over time by the
individuality he goes on and says
circumstances situation customs which on
the one hand are shown is already there
right the
to date the individual they're already
there were born into a society we're
born into a family we you know run into
is if we could become apprentices we
enter the military there are norms there
in place before us and he says on the
other hand there present in this
specific individuality and this
expresses only the indeterminate nature
of the individuality which is not the
point under consideration so he says if
these circumstances all this stuff over
here had not been then of course the
individual could not have assimilated
them I conform to them reacted against
them ignored them they are a given and
the individual does have to exercise his
or her choice her freedom her
interpretation in relation to them but
the fact that there is that play that
slippage means that it is not simply
determined by what the circumstances by
the externals so he goes on and he says
the individual would not have become
what he is all those elements present in
the state of the world are the universal
substance the fact however that the
state of the world has particularized
itself in this particular individual and
it is such an individual that is to be
comprehended implies it must also have
particularized itself on its own account
and have operated on an individual in
this specific character which is given
itself only in this way would it have
made itself into this specific
individual that he is so he goes on he
says if the Constitution which the
external world is spontaneously given
itself is that which is manifest in the
individuality the latter would be
comprehended from the former what is all
this thing it's saying that in this
dialectic between individual and world
or individual and culture or individual
and family individual and institution
the institution and the norms governing
it particularized themselves become real
in individuals on the other hand the
individual
as the locus of this are deciding for
themselves how this is actually going to
play itself out so in a certain sense
these are you might not you might say
not even really ideals they are ghosts
they are kind of shadowy shapes floating
back and forth and it's up to the
individual how they're going to
assimilate that and make them into
spirit diced red little play on words
there because ghosts and spirit in
English two different words are the same
word in German Geist well spirit could
be ghosts could be could be spooked as
well so he goes on he says if the
Constitution which the external world is
spontaneously given itself is that which
is manifest in the individuality right
it would be comprehended from the former
and then he switches to this interesting
metaphor he talks in spatial terms and
there's a transformation that's taking
place here so he says imagine that we
have two galleries of pictures and
they're reflecting each other their rep
they're representing each other they're
medically connected with each other he
says we have a double gallery of
pictures one of which would be the
reflection of the other the one the
gallery of external circumstances the
external right which he goes on he says
completely determine and circumscribed
the individual or at least we think that
they do the other is the individual and
we think that the relation is just this
way right but we've seen that the
individual and the pictures that the
individual has within him or her is not
merely replicating or mirroring what's
going on in the external world now Hagel
says that we have a transformation
that's taking place here we can think
instead of about galleries like this we
can think of a sphere and this is you
know not that three-dimensional making a
little bit three-dimensional by adding
that there we go now maybe it looks like
a sphere to you maybe not because my
drawing is not the best what's key about
this is that we have the surface of the
sphere right the externality of it
right and that's that gallery here
that's this all these pictures here and
then we have the intern ality which is
the individual and the center of the
sphere an interesting way of depicting
this and it's in certain respects more
more realistic than talking about
galleries facing each other in part
because the individual is at the center
of the universe now of course we have
multiple individuals will talk more
about that later but so far as we're
seeing it here what's going on here the
individual is deciding the meaning of
what is on the periphery
but the spherical surface the world of
the individual has at once an ambiguous
meaning it is the actual state of the
world as it is in and for itself and it
is the world of the individual it is the
latter either insofar as the individual
has merely coalesced with that world has
let it just as it is enter into him
behaving towards it as a merely formal
consciousness or on the other hand it is
the world of the individual in the sense
that the actual world has given has been
transformed by the individual since on
account of this freedom the actual world
is capable of having this twofold
meaning the world of the individual is
to be comprehended only from the
individual himself and the influence on
the individual of the actual world
conceived as existing in and for itself
receives through the individual the
absolutely opposite significance that is
that the individual either allows free
play to the stream of the actual world
flowing in upon it or else breaks it off
and transforms it the result of this
however is that psychological necessity
becomes an empty phrase so empty that
there exists the absolute possibility
that what is supposed to have had this
influence could just as well not have
had it
now in paragraph 307 Hagel is going to
continue working with this metaphor of
the sphere and you have to imagine i'm
not the best drawer when it comes to
this sort of thing we've got a seer here
and we've got the individual right at
the middle of it and these arrows that
are that are depicted here are
representing the influence of everything
from the outside pressing towards the
inside of the individual and the
individual we might think of as
something like a point at the middle
something that's collapsed within under
the weight of sociological or
psychological determinism or at least
the laws that are supposed to be
pressing and their influence upon the
person and now you notice that there's
one other arrow there's this one here
which I should probably highlight a bit
more this arrow which is the individual
and his or her own influence upon her
upon themselves coming through that
that's fear breaking through it breaking
through as Hagel says any sort of
psychological determinism that is
supposed to be affecting them so Hagel
says the surface of this fear is the
actual state of the world he also says
that that's in and for itself which is a
rather strange thing to say particularly
given that we would we would easily say
that the world is in itself right it has
that sort of beingness of just being
just being as it is it's a given as he
said in the last paragraph why is it for
itself well that's because the world is
not just a world of mute things of
nature pressing in upon the person it's
a social world it's a world of other
spiritual entities of other
consciousnesses and that's why it has
the shape that it does that's why the
laws that pertain to it could press in
upon the individual because they've been
made through the actions through the
choices through you know the the history
of other individuals they represent
culture at least whatever culture there
happens to be they represent the
sure of institutions ranging from the
family all the way up to the nation
state or the you know culture industry
in our own time and all of that is
indeed as Hagel says in and for itself
usually the in and for itself is the end
point isn't it but here it's just a
beginning point because the individual
as it turns out supersedes the
individual transcends the in and for
itself of the actual state of the world
so how does that happen well he tells us
so the spherical surface the world of
the individual has an ambiguous meaning
any time we have ambiguity in Hagel we
have a doubling a splitting that's
taking place an important movement so he
says it's the actual state of the world
and the world of the individual and it's
the latter either insofar as the
individual has merely coalesced with
that world that is one possibility the
social pressure simply exerted on the
individual makes the individual what he
or she is in a certain sense they're an
individual in name only they're really
just a representative of what's going on
there sort of like a knight or a bishop
on the chess board that only has meaning
in terms of the game of chess that's not
the way human beings most of the time
actually are however so he goes on and
he says the influence on the individual
of the actual world conceived as
existing and in for itself receives
through the individual the absolutely
opposite significance this pressure is
transformed he says the individual
either allows free play to the stream of
the actual world flowing in upon itself
or else breaks it off and transforms it
so this is very important the individual
determines the influence that the world
can have the individual transforms the
elements of the world and the forces the
pressure that it brings the influences
and decides in some way not necessarily
in any rational way but in some way what
is going to have that effect upon the
individual what is going to shape it so
the individual
in a certain respect self shaping but
not in a Promethean form of just you
know making itself out of nothing that's
not really a Promethean form anyway but
that's often the way we talk about it
rather it's doing so by adapting the
world to it just as much as it adapts
itself to the world there's often
ruptures going on within this as well so
he says the result of this is that
psychological necessity becomes an empty
phrase it becomes meaningless to say
that we have laws that tell us exactly
how a person is going to behave that
becomes nonsense from Hagel's
perspective so empty he says that there
exists the absolute possibility that
what is supposed to have this influence
could just as well not have had it why
is that the case well because the
individual is the one who decides what
in this surface actually does have
influence upon them
thus there is no question of a being
which would be in and for itself and was
supposed to constitute one aspect and
the universal aspect at that of a law
individuality is what it's world is the
world that is its own individuality is
itself the cycle of its action in which
it is exhibit itself as an actual world
and as simply and solely the unity of
the world is given and the world that is
made a unity whose sides do not fall
apart as in the conception of
psychological law into a world that in
itself is already given and an
individuality existing on its own
account or if these sides are thus
considered each by itself there exists
no necessity and no law of their
connection with one another
this very short section of observing
reason has come to a close in paragraph
308 a very short paragraph and we see
that similarly to with the previous
movement in the first section of
observing reason observing nature where
we ran into ultimately a check we
weren't able to have laws in the sense
that we wanted to have them as something
that you know observing reason could
generate for the world we see that the
same thing happens with the laws of
thought or their transformation into
psychological laws there is a kind of
slippage there there's a kind of escape
on the part of the subjectivity so Hagel
is going to talk about this in terms of
individuality this is very important
because in the next section of
observation of the relation of
self-consciousness to its immediate
actuality physiognomies and phrenology
we are going to be focusing yet more on
the individual and trying to make sense
of the individual in terms of his or her
body and you know all these other things
rather than just merely the external
factors here we're seeing that
individuality introduces necessarily a
sort of freedom which undoes the kind of
necessity that we were hoping to gain
and in laws so he says there's no
question of a being which would be in
and for itself that was the world right
and was supposed to constitute one
aspect and the universal aspect of that
of a law though the world does not
determine the individual individuality
says is what it's world is that's a very
interesting thing to say individuality
is shaped by the world the environment
that it takes in that it allows to form
it to some degree but against which it
reacts also or reshapes it or
reinterprets it and decides what it's
going to take a take from the world and
allow to determine it or to condition it
and what it's going to say no no
going to ignore that or reject it and
Hagel will talk about the cycle of its
action the cycle of the individuals
action in this case he says it is itself
the cycle of its action in which it is
exhibited itself as an actual world and
simply and solely the unity of the world
is given in the world it has made so
what are we talking about there the
individual of course is not the entirety
of the world but the individual is kind
of the privileged node from which the
world makes its sense from which the
world has its meaning and we could say
what about multiple individuals Hagel's
not concerned with that at this point is
just looking at the single individual or
you might say if we want to think ahead
the individual in the abstract but he
also does talk here about two important
things the world as given that is the
world that psychological laws thought
they could look at and say AHA now we
know everything about the factors that
are going to shape the person and the
world has made what it means to be a
human being is in part not merely to
accept Givens but to transform them into
something new or even something old if
we want but it's still us transforming
it it's still the individual the human
being doing that through its action
doesn't necessarily have to be in any
sort of very self conscious way this is
something that we all do all the time
when kids are making their way into
school and figuring out their place in
the pecking order and determining how
they're going to fit in or even the
style of you know how they're going to
behave in the cafeteria in relation to
the other kids in relation to the space
in relation to the traditions already
established there when they innovate and
do something new when they you know
resuscitate something that kids you know
several generations before them had done
that they have no idea was done before
that's what we're talking about here
when people in a workplace decide that
they're going to do things in this way
using micro
soft word and have this go around that's
part of what Hagel's talking about here
this is not something that necessarily
has to have you know massive abstract
world historical connotations this is
something that we can all relate to in
our everyday life in our institutions of
the family in our institutions of how we
consume and enjoy things I think about
what you do with your Netflix or your
YouTube you know watch later Q any of
these sorts of things can be understood
in this way our clothing can be
understood in this way our appearance
our interactions with each other get
waxing a little bit prolix here but I
want to get back to the main point he
says if those sides are thus considered
each by themselves there exists no
necessity and no law of their connection
with each other why don't we have a law
at this point because individuality is
calling the shots these things are
actually connected together and perhaps
even unified the world as given the
world is made individuality is deciding
what's going on and at this point we
really have a Hagel who sounds very very
much like a certain you know later
French philosopher who will use hey
galleon categories but is not himself a
Hegelian and I again leave that fuedeh
to figure out to read between the lines
we are now finished with this subsection
and ready to move on to the next
subsection of observing reason